à paris jean-paul kauffmann raconte ses
trois ans de détention au liban c'était
ce matin au cours d'une conférence de
presse
l'ex-otage français qui était
visiblement très fatigué a tout d'abord
adresser un grand merci à tous ceux qui
l'ont sorti at il dit de l'enfer de la
détention
ensuite jean paul kauffmann a évoqué
tour à tour dieu la bible et les livres
qui lui ont permis de tenir le coup
pendant mille trente sept jours
témoignage au micro de jérôme boni c'est
vrai que c'est un peu le piètre alors
aussi de re découvrir dieu et dans
d'autres circonstances on l'est dans le
malheur bon ben on se bat on prie et
puis on se tourne vers dieu là il
fallait sans doute que ce soit fait dans
des circonstances piètre notre île dans
ce malheur oui c'est vrai dieu et la
bible bonbons beaucoup pds étaient très
curieux d'ailleurs parce que bon dans
les livres lesquels les livres j'ai eu a
certainement pas mal de livres
et puis on y les perdais tout le temps
dans nos 18 déménagement on les
retrouvait plus des ces gares etc
mais la bible elle suivait tout le temps
dieu comme soutien moral mais aussi ses
compagnons de détention
marcel carton et marcel fontaine et la
littérature avec des livres précieux
parce que rares comme le deuxième tome
de guerre et paix qu'il a lu 22 fois
voyez par exemple ce texte là là moi ça
va toujours tentant le prince andré
parle de la mort
il va mourir le prince andré il se dit
est-ce vraiment la mort se dit le prince
andré en considérant d'un regard neuf
ans vieux l'herbe c'est la veille de ces
pendant la bataille de borodino l'erve
l'armoise et le filet de fumée
s'élevaient de la balle noir
tourbillonnantes et le prince andré dit
je ne peux pas je ne veux pas mourir
j'aime la vie j'aime ces serbes cette
terre il avait ça m'a profondément
éprouvé par la lente agonie sous ses
yeux de son ami michel seurat kaufmann
libre n'est pas prêt de retrouver la
sérénité
il ne dort que deux heures par nuit
encore hanté par ses trois ans je vécu
dans la peur quotidienne de l'exécution
quand il y avait des alertes là quelques
fois il entend les bruits qu'ils étaient
sur le qui-vive et et alors ils
ouvraient les portes et vont ne voyez
rien mais bon il y avait certainement la
grenade qu'ils étaient prêts à lancer
s'il y avait mon les tentatives de
délivrance de
de l'extérieur bon évidemment là on
pense à redire on va peut-être dans
quelques minutes
je vais mourir et c'est bon c'est ça
c'est quand même ça ça vous donne des
palpitations